c'est le problème de l'intégration
être étranger quand on adhère on épouse
les valeurs du pays qui vous accueillent
ne pose aucun aucune difficulté
aujourd'hui le nombre d'étrangers qui
sont arrivés en un accueil en situation
légale quasiment 500 000 chaque année
500 000 chaque année qui se qui sera
joute et donc aujourd'hui on a plus la
capacité à assimiler aux valeurs de la
République ces personnes parce qu'elles
puissent tout travailler il y a 500 000
étrangers au chômage à ce qu'elles
puissent connaître la langue de la
République et puis il y a des problèmes
de communautarisme on l'a vu qui sont
liés à cette immigration de masse il y a
des problèmes de délinquance c'est pas
moi qui le dit c'est le ministre de
l'Intérieur puisque il a été je le dis
presque courageusement le premier à
faire ce lien il a pas fait grand chose
pour corriger mais à dire il y a un lien
entre délinquance et immigration 24% des
détenus en prison aujourd'hui sont des
étrangers vous avez cité le chiffre à
peu près 7% de la population
24 alors sur les étranges vous parlez
des immigrés sur les étrangers c'est
presque 8 3 millions 3 millions 5
millions il y en a 24 % donc trois fois
plus proportionnellement en prison donc
il y a ce lien
90% des vols à la tire dans les
transports parisiens sont commis par des
étrangers donc il y a un sujet il faut
qu'on intègre mieux ce qui sont ici il
faut que ceux qui n'ont pas le droit d'y
être repartent chez eux et il faut qu'on
arrête que notre pays accueille trop
d'étrangers j'étais hier au Danemark le
Danemark il a envoyé un message très
clair en disant on ne peut pas
accueillir certaines personnes et donc
ils ne seront pas bien accueillis ici et
du coup ils vont ailleurs ce message de
dissuasion comporter les Danois au-delà
des des mesures qui sont en application
ils ont lancé un message ce message il a
été entendu nous en on dit c'est open
bar vous avez les prestations sociales
dès le premier jour les allocations
familiales vous avez une multitude
d'aide l'aide médicale d'État vous avez
le droit aujourd'hui de venir vous
soigner en France parce que dans votre
pays il y a pas le même niveau de soin
tout ça c'est une forme de naïveté les
Français ne l'acceptent plus et sa nuit
à la cohésion de notre pays
Gilles moi ce que j'aime bien monsieur
ciottis c'est que vous n'êtes pas langue
de bois et là vous l'êtes moins que
jamais c'est à dire que là vous faites
directement explicitement le lien entre
immigration et délinquance c'est pas moi
ce sont les statistiques vous dites sur
le plateau s'il y avait moins d'immigrés
aujourd'hui il y aurait moins
d'insécurité ou de sentiments
d'insécurité en France moins
d'insécurité directement les immigrés
sont responsables de l'insécurité
majoritairement en tout cas c'est pas
moi qui l'ai dit je le solide mais je le
confirme le préfet de police de Paris
l'ancien préfet de police le ministre de
l'Intérieur monsieur Darmanin pas dans
la même famille politique ils partent
sur les bases de les du service
statistique du ministère de l'Intérieur
il dit oui on y était mais on n'y est
plus 50% des actes de délinquance commis
à Paris à Lyon à Marseille donc dans les
grandes villes sont aujourd'hui du fait
d'étrangers c'est une statistique après
chacun y trouve son interprétation mais
pourquoi parce qu'aujourd'hui très
clairement notre pays n'a plus la
capacité à accueillir autant d'étrangers
parce qu'elle n'a plus la capacité à les
intégrer comme il conviendrait et tous
les immigrés qui travaillent dans la
restauration dans des tas de secteurs
qui sans eux ne fonctionneraient plus
aujourd'hui monsieur sautier
moi je suis plus favorable à
l'immigration de travail que
l'immigration familiale ou quelquefois
aussi au
dévoiement du droit d'asile qui permet
de faire rentrer aujourd'hui chaque
année 130 000 personnes dont environ 80
000 sont des faux demandeurs d'asile ils
utilisent vous voulez pas de
regroupement familial alors je veux
limiter le regroupement familial nous ce
que nous proposons ce sont des plafonds
maximum qui est une forme de quota
aujourd'hui on a l'année dernière on a
donné 320 330 000 titres de séjour en
France nous disons il faut il faut pas
dépasser je prends l'exemple c'est pas
un chiffre qui a été mais on ferait
voter chaque année par le Parlement
plafondisant cette année on dépasse pas
les 75000 et là dedans il y en a 15000
pour le regroupement familial il y a 40
000 étudiants il y en a 30 000 qui
viennent travailler enfin j'ai pas le
compte je sais pas s'il est exact voilà
et donc
ceux qui arrivent au-delà du seuil ils
attendent l'année d'après mais le
regroupement familial aujourd'hui il est
automatique il est automatique parce que
on doit subir la règle qui nous a
imposée par un article d'une convention
internationale et d'ailleurs dans
d'autres proposition de loi nous disons
si les Français le décident aucune
normes internationale ne pourra être
supérieur à la volonté du peuple pour
vous la loi l'immigration elle est
il y a une urgence à la faire pour vous
bien sûr parce que la situation elle est
grave on voit bien que tous les chiffres
se dégradent jamais nous n'avons
accueilli autant d'étrangers dans notre
pays jamais autant chaque année c'est
l'équivalent d'une très grande ville
est-ce que c'est pas de de certains
talents de certains mais on les choisit
comment on les choisit il y a pour
choisir un bon immigré qui qui quitte
son pays parce qu'il y a la famille mais
qui arrive en France qui va travailler à
un mauvais immigré qui quitte son pays
qui va profiter des aides qui a foutent
nos bordel ici seulement on différencie
quand il est sur le bateau en pleine mer
comment on sait lequel est le bon lequel
est le mauvais lequel on garde dans
lequel on devient le bateau c'est pas le
bon vecteur
c'est pas le bon vecteur pour arriver si
on veut arriver on va faire une demande
de visa dans un consulat à l'étranger il
y a des cartes talois qui s'appelle
talents et compétences notamment pour
accueillir des professionnels de santé
il y en a donc moi je dis je préfère une
immigration de travail mais légale vous
parliez tout à l'heure dans les
restaurants je pense que c'est un peu le
projet de Monsieur Darmanin c'est pour
ça qu'on est contre c'est il veut
régulariser ce qui travaille au noir
ceux qui sont des clandestins ça je m'y
refuse parce que si on commence à
régulariser comme c'est fait aujourd'hui
il y a 30 000 clandestins environ chaque
année qui sont régularisés ça veut dire
quoi on lance un message à tous ceux qui
veulent venir et qui vont se dire une
fois qu'on a mis un pied en France en
Europe puis en France on est régularisé
ça ça marche pas